I just think it's you've got to rethink
the entire thing but to break through
the noise you on on by definition you
have to do something fundamentally
different than what everybody else is
doing and everybody else is doing the
same thing I call it the Taylor Swift
rule so I think so I think Taylor Swift
hacked culture I think Kanye does it as
well believe it or not here's what they
do you scale the unscalable if you want
to break through the noise today so let
me explain what Taylor Swift's very good
at if she knows that when people tweet
her and say Taylor come to my wedding
and sing me a song she actually doesn't
here's why she does it
the 75-minute allocation of her time to
do something like that is not ROI
positive for Taylor based on what she
makes for her time however the
amplification of doing something that
makes no sense on paper is where she
gets all her value so I get yelled out
by all my smartest CEO friends the most
fancy gals and guys on earth for still
answering all these tweets and emails
and replying one by one on snapchat but
I know that depth is far more
interesting than with in a world where
the width has just become completely
obnoxiously loud and impossible to break
through truth is there are characters
that look like me running around there
are people that understand I know not
that many but but but you can get
somebody into an honest conversation
because they do not have aligned
interests they don't and the only they
start the relationship with knowing each
other not at all and that's the closest
on a line interest they'll ever be and
this is all that happens and it breaks
so to me let's just [ __ ] get it out
of the way I just think communications
very valuable like it just works and
just nobody does it like really I mean a
great communicators win in life
especially you know back to why I
married my wife five seconds into our
first date especially you're lucky
enough to find another great
communicator and that's where we're
client relationships and that's where
business partnerships card I just think
it's better to know that it's not gonna
work upfront
[Music]